children crush fallen leaves with their
feet they live at an orphanage near the
capital Katmandu
school exercise books are recycled to
finish writing and Hallmark and not
youth this year new materials are made
from hold the ground-up leaves are added
to this mix of water and paper it's not
exactly a high-tech process but it works
these are biomass briquettes the
orphanage is funded by private
contributions and doesn't have the money
for firewood we need a lot of money to
buy food and to buy tree just like a
waste of money tree and wood and so we
were searching for a new substitute of a
wood so the briquettes replace wood for
heating that helps protect the local
forest which is an important source of
oxygen and provides a home for many
animals it is tough in the environment
and the year will be polluted and the
environment will be bad in such a busy
environment the orphanage is located
near a Brickyard which burns through
wood supplies at a furious pace it's
also the largest employer in the village
the Brickyard takes up a lot of space so
did the farmers fields there's not much
room left for trees in fact over the
last 25 years Nepal has lost about 1/4
of its forest land
this orphanage is home to nearly 60
children Yamada and Suresh Conti care
for the kids almost as if they were
their own the couple's own two children
live here too on the roof of the
orphanage there's a makeshift
drainage chute for collecting water and
solar thermal equipment for heating it
it's a high-tech solution that provides
the orphanage with hot water the
orphanage recently installed two small
units that contain solar modules for
generating electricity
let's give it up for another now we can
read at night and now we can watch TV
get it
TV area now just another good it's time
for dinner
sometimes they do have to use firewood
but the biomass briquettes provide
enough fuel to heat two small cooking
stoves the briquettes are actually a
better fuel than wood for several
reasons they catch fire more quickly and
generate more heat and there's less
smoke to Terrace and jolly is a widow
she lives at the orphanage with her two
children but she also looks after rupak
and the rest of the kids the children
are hungry sand jelly serves up dal Bhat
a traditional Nepali dish made of
steamed rice and cooked lentil soup
Suresh and Amara also provide the
children with spiritual nourishment this
includes regular prayer sessions and
singing the orphanage is run on
Christian principles and the couple
tries to reflect their values in their
everyday lives I try to be like a mother
to these children I do everything I can
to show them a mother's love we raise
the children we prevent them not to
become a street children and we are
providing them a good education and we
make them to learn and law these girls
are preparing their lessons for the
following day it's not easy to study
when there are 14 of you living in one
room but at least there's enough
electricity to keep the lights on
the electricity comes from solar powered
batteries that store sunlight over the
course of the day the batteries power
the lamps the children use at night when
there is no electricity we we read on
candle know now here is solar light we
always studies here's another potential
source of energy the orphanage owns four
buffaloes and they create a lot of
manure there are small user friendly
plants that will convert that manure
into methane gas they're made are around
50 cases of cow dung each day and if we
can reuse them as a biogas then we can
have a biogas to cook food the children
at the orphanage lead active lives and
these new alternative sources of energy
have helped them to expand their
horizons and they've learned new ways to
work together to help save the
environment